hey everyone this is Kevin from the test
website calm today we are in the final
round round 9 of the 2015 London chess
classic we've had coverage pretty much
all day so hopefully y'all have enjoyed
all the commentary our last and final
round the players are going to be Magnus
Carlsen is gonna be playing the white
pieces his opponents Alexander goodie
ship is going to be playing the black
pieces both these players are near the
top so depending on how they do we could
see a victor or depending on how some of
the other players do we could see a tie
at the top and then there is a
tiebreaker so we'll go ahead and get
into it Magnus Carlsen starts out with
Knight to f3 pawn near to c5 pawn here
to e4 this is the Sicilian defense just
a small variation as far as how we got
there but definitely the Sicilian
defense pawn here to d6 Bishop e2 b5 so
this is the Moscow variation not
something we see all that often usually
it's just gonna be the pawn here to d4
capture recapture and then Knight here
to f6 is pretty common we could later on
see pawn here to a6 depending on how
black wants to continue but we don't
always see Bishop here to b5 so always
nice to see Magnus Carlsen trying some
new things out that aren't as common as
you typically see at high level chess
9002 d7 I really thought Magnus Charles
might just take here he could have done
some preparation and just thought you
know getting this not off the board I
don't really need my LightSquared Bishop
potentially that's gonna be fine but he
decides to go ahead and castle after
pawn here 286 he plays Bishop back here
to d3 and this is another one of those
don't see it all that often kind of that
new tech that magnus carlsen is trying
out too you know he's prepared for this
and so Bishop to d3 kind of blocking
this pawn here on d2 for the time being
which in essence also blocks the bishop
here on a c1 so we'll look to kind of do
some work with that later
Knight here to f6 rook over here to e1
protecting this pawn right here pawn
here to b5 so we have a good ishik
looking to attack on the Queen side
while - Carlson is gonna start to put a
lot of pressure on the King side upon up
here to c4 there's kind of two ways to
kind of
the pond coming here to c4 we have
paneer 2 B 3
we have pawn here to c4 c4 is probably
the more aggressive of the two moves and
so we decided to go and play pawn here
to see for now pawn here to g5 is very
interesting from Ganesha oak and this is
one of those moves where it kind of
makes you sit up in your seat if you're
magnus carlsen you could easily just
exchange over here
okay you guys light square bishop
involved into the game paneer to g5 is
pretty much saying it's it's go time I'm
gonna go ahead and start to attack on
the Queen side
I'm almost urging you to attack me on
the King side which is what Magnus
Carlsen probably want to do anyway so
magic Carlsen kind of straightened up in
his seat a little bit and they played
Knight takes on g5 and now Knight comes
down here to e5 forcing the bishop back
here - E - it's kind of awkward if the
bishop comes here to c2 because then
Bishop to g4 it's just kind of ugly for
white to kind of get into so decides to
go and play kind of the safer route of
Bishop here to e2 we now see the pawn
take here on c4 probably a little bit
worse is for the night taking here on c4
then the bishop could take the pawn
captures here but then the Queen could
come out here to a4 check kind of
forcing a move you can see Knight over
here to d7 you can see Knight come here
to a3 attacking this pawn here is going
to fall why it's gonna have a really
nice position here and blacks gonna have
a hard time really castling and feeling
safe about it so that's going to be very
good for whites at black decides to go
ahead and capture a little bit
differently play pawn taking here on c4
leaving his nights here on e5 and in
case it needs to protect over there on
the King side my favorite c3 just
continued the developed for magnus
carlsen work over here to b8 attacking
the semi-open file you always want your
uggs to be attacking your controller the
semi-open files or the completely open
files they they do a lot better if they
can control more of the board rook over
here to f1 this is one of the spots
where I really wanted Magnus cross him
to be super aggressive he had the move
pawn here to f4 forcing the knight to
move then I could come down here to a d3
kind of
attacking here you could see the bishop
take the pawn capture here now the Queen
come out here to a four queen here to d7
now the Queen swings over here to see
for threatening this square here on f7
since the night right here nice little
outpost move a night here on g5 is kind
of protecting this so after kind of a
move here you can see the Queen take
here on d3 it's an advanced you know
situation the Magnus crossing can go
into but these pawns here on e4 @ e RF
for just really allow him to put a lot
of pressure on the King side but after
this pawn moves away you can push
forward with pawn here to d4 give his
dark squared bishop involved into the
game later on he could have a nice
little outpost here on a d5 I really
like this I was hoping that he did this
but in the game he decided to go with a
little bit safer move and played rook
here to f1 we now see pawn here to h6
forcing the Knights move Knight comes
back here to f3 now Knight down here to
a d3 Knight here to e 1 & magicka
Carlson had a few options he could have
easily taken here with his bishop here
on d3 and that would have been fine pawn
recaptures this is all fine but instead
decides to go ahead and play Knight here
to e1 and this ship decides to go for a
little interesting move over here Knight
taking here on a b2 now after the bishop
takes the rook swings down here and then
the bishop takes here on c4 so allowing
his opponents kind of recapture and have
a centralized bishop here on C for
controlling the square here on f7 which
right now is kind of a weakness the only
square kind of touching it right now is
the King here on e8 so interesting for
me to allow Magnus crossing one of the
best attacking players in the world to
kind of have this position but good
Ishika didn't take too much time on that
and so we decided that was that the path
he wanted to take now rook up here to be
for attacking the bishop Queen airs at
e2 defending that Bishop and now Bishop
to g7 getting ready to castle on the
Kings side if he wants to not appear to
c2 forcing the rook back here to be sick
b6 or rook here to b1 threatening to
just go ahead and exchange right here
and then castle on the King side so
Magnus Carlsen kind of have it has a
game plan and that game plan is go ahead
and tack on the King side
his king is much safer he has three
pawns in front of it but his opponent
this sheikh he has only two pawns in
front of it and this send me open foul
right here on the G file so the dish is
gonna be looking to kind of safeguard as
king over here probably h8 or h7
depending on what material is kind of
left since there's a light squared
bishop more than like you're gonna see
King here to h8 but the magic Rustin is
just gonna look to put a lot of pressure
on this G file on the opposite side of
the board good issues gonna try to just
hold on and then eventually break over
on the Queen side break through and just
see if he can kind of make something
happen right now he doesn't have enough
material to kind of push forward on the
King side of magnus carlsen and magnus
carlsen is king is pretty safe so we do
see exchange on board rook here to b6
Queen over here now Knight over here to
e3 as we kind of talked about Magnus
Carlsen needs to get his material
involved over on the King side upon here
to e6 and now pawn up here to f4 so
Magnus Carlsen has started his attack on
the King side black now plays rook or
King over here to h8 as we talked about
before pawn up here to f5 just kind of
forcing and being as aggressive as
possible paneer to a5 pawn here to a4
Magnus Carlsen is trying to kind of keep
any pressure that Black has over on the
Queen side he doesn't want to commit too
much material over here but does want to
go ahead and make sure that nothing
crazy happens over here Queen here to d8
pawn here to h3 looking to kind of push
forward if he needs to also kind of
stopping this Knight here to g4 which
later could be problematic if this
Knight is not here on e3 they shook now
plays Queen here to e7 and we see Bishop
come out here to a6 pretty interesting
Magnus Carlsen decided that his
LightSquared Bishop wasn't doing too
much after the pawn came here to e6 kind
of blocking off this light square
diagonal he just really didn't want to
have to deal with this light square
bishop right here kind of controlling
this long day I gotta right here so he
thought his opponent slice of a bishop
was a little bit more powerful than his
his opponent also has a double bishop
pair so decided to want to go ahead and
get that off the board so after the
Queen recaptures Knight here to h5 he
has two ways to kind of stop
he has root beer to f3 this stops the
night coming here to g3 he also has
Knight to e2 I personally preferred
Knight to e2 gets another piece over on
this side of the board also you know
stops this Knight here to g3 if he needs
to and then later on he can start to
push up the board with Knight to f4 if
he wants to be pretty aggressive but
magnus carlsen decided to play rook here
to f3 he had other ideas for this night
here on a c3 after the route comes over
here to g8 trying to make sure that Y
does not super control this semi open
file right here Magnus Carlsen continues
with Knight to b5 so
Magnus Carlsen looking to have this
outpost here on b5 and somewhat control
a little bit of the Queen side he founds
a kink in the armor with this pawn here
on d6 so he has both his knight and his
queen both attacking this pawn so
instead of just throwing everything at
the the King side since good issue has
kind of focused all his material now on
just defending the Kings side instead of
really pushing forward with an advantage
on the Queen's that Magnus Carlsen has
found a small little kink in the armor
we now see Bishop here to e5 trying to
defend this pawn here on d6 Knight
appear to g4 threatening this Bishop
putting all the pressure or recognizing
that he has a small advantage right now
a queen here to h4 we now see an
exchange off the board and now the
knight takes here on e5 after that takes
now the Queen comes over here to e6 so
Magnus Carlsen has been setting this up
for a while he now has a very active
Queen on board you know he can look to
take here on e5 check his knights that
he does need to get this involved into
the board but he has a fairly safe queen
or king excuse me here on a g1 and a
very active queen so looking to really
push forward and take control of this
game he does have one extra pawn on
board so good this chick's kind of has
his back against the wall and he used to
figure out how he can go ahead and turn
this into maybe a drop or if Magnus
cross makes a mistake turn this into a
victory now from here go district really
needs to play Queen to g5 it's the
one kind of move that allows them to
continue to put pressure we have Queen
you know threat here Queen here to G to
stops a lot of the threats Queen here to
e5 as we've discussed before
instead he plays Queen here to e1 so
check a now King up here to h2 root down
here to G to sacrifice now the King
captures and then he plays Queen here to
d2 now after he plays you know the rook
down here sacrifice from here he really
needs to play Queen here to e2 because
after the King comes here to g1 now he
can get that material back Queen here to
f3 capture the rook he can now bring his
knight involved into the game it's gonna
be the difficult for him to checkmate
but at least it allows him to kind of
dance around it's gonna be just a pain
for Magnus Carlsen I have to deal with
all these Queen checks over and over
again so that's kind of the route he
should have gone in the game he played
Queen here to d2 but it's actually very
easy for Magnus Carlsen to defend
against this he just plays King here to
g1 make sure his king is out of range of
any checks shenanigans that black has
bring is night down here to g3 and now
the Queen's gonna come here to e1 rook
here to f1 Queen up here trying to
attack but eventually after the king
comes here to G - there's no more checks
and there's no real way for Ganesha to
continue to attack right here so after
this move we see good ishik resign in
this position and magnus carlsen a wins
the game before i've had people ask you
know how could this game continue
Ganesha could have tried night here to
f4 from here we could see the rook
capture after the pawn captures here
Queen over here to h6 check we could see
King here to G eights now just gobbling
up all this material you can see that
black is really far behind the material
Queen up here to e2 and kind of just
march up the board it's gonna be very
easy for Magnus Carlsen to avoid kind of
a continuous check in the draw so the
King kind of dance around but the King's
just going to start pushing forward on
this G file and then making his Queen
involved have an easy checkmate he can
even push his pawns up the board if you
needs to for additional horsepower but
all-in-all there's nothing at issue can
kind of do so he decides to resign what
was kind of interesting in this
tournament after magnus carlsen won this
we had a three weights high at the top
magnus carlsen really needed a victory
in the London chess classic to go ahead
and win the entire grand chest tour and
in the the first round of kind of tie
breakers we had Maxine about shindig
enough and he played a nice giri he won
in a three game match so Maxine played
Magnus Carlsen in the finals of the
tiebreaker Magnus Carlsen went on to a
win that's one and a half points to a
half a point he won one of the matches
and tied the other one so Magnus Carlsen
with this victory of the tournament
ended up winning the entire Grange has
tour because of everyone else that was
above him kind of faltered you had Topol
i've had just had a horrible tournament
you had Levon Aronian didn't play as
well as he probably could have and then
you had Nakamura who was in second place
behind to a bluff but then two key
losses earlier in the tournaments kind
of doomed his faith so all in all Magnus
Carlsen at the last hour of both won the
London Chest Classic and went on to win
the grand chest tour in the first
inaugural year so congratulations to him
the world champion just going out there
and dominating like he always does so
hopefully you guys enjoyed this
tournament one of the best tournaments
we've had all year so if you haven't
watched all the coverage from all the
different rounds I posted some on
YouTube the rest on the website make
sure you check those out at the chest
website comm there's a featured section
for recent uploads you can check it out
there but hopefully you guys enjoyed
this match and the rest of the
tournament and I'll see you guys in the
next one thanks for watching